ist ein Haufen Kabelsalat Saboteure
stürzen die Deutsche Bahn am Wochenende
ins Chaos und jetzt dieses exklusiv Foto
und das zeigt wie simpel das ganze
offensichtlich war sie sehen hier fünf
durchtrennte Kabel und das reichte
offenbar bereits um den gesamten Verkehr
im Norden Deutschlands und nach
Nordrhein-Westfalen lahm zu legen und
klar ist jetzt auch das waren
professionelle Saboteure die offenbar
wussten was sie machen und wie es geht
die wussten wo diese Kabel verlegt sind
und welche sie Kappen mussten und die
Frage bleibt wer hätte denn ein
Interesse
haben die Russen eine weitere Drohung
wahr gemacht nämlich die Drohung
Vergeltungsmaßnahmen gegen westliche
Staaten durchzuführen die die Ukraine
und die Sanktionen gegen Russland
unterstützen ist das hier solch eine
kriegerische Aktion auf deutschem Boden
bei Herne in Nordrhein-Westfalen durch
trennen professionell vorgehende Täter
Kabelstränge für die Kommunikation der
Bahnen das Bundeskriminalamt hält
staatlich gesteuerte Sabotage zumindest
für denkbar auch der Staatsschutz in NRW
schließt politische Motivation nicht aus
zu ermitteln wegen gefährlichen
Eingriffs in den Bahnverkehr da eine
politische Motivation nicht ausschließen
ist der startschutz bei uns mit den
Aufgaben betraut worden für den
terrorexperten peter Neumann ist eine
Verwicklung Russlands in diese Vorfälle
denkbar vorstellbar ist es deshalb weil
wir wissen dass die Russen natürlich
seit Jahren
Anschläge auf die kritische
Infrastruktur in Europa verüben vor
allem auf die cyber-infrastruktur fast
täglich werden da Anschläge gemeldet wer
auch immer hinter den Sabotageakten der
letzten Zeit steckt Gas an den
ostseepipelines und ein Angriff der den
norddeutschen Bahnverkehr lahm liegt es
sind neue Mittel im politischen Konflikt
auf die wir bisher keine Antwort haben
im Gegenteil wie die Bahn in diesem
Youtube-Video gehen wir recht locker mit
Informationen über unsere Infrastruktur
um zu locker für Kriegszeiten hier
halten wir noch einmal an nicht
spektakulär aber ungemein wichtig ist in
diesem modulgebäude eines von vier
elektronischen Stellwerken der
Neubaustrecke untergebracht dieser Akte
der Sabotage haben ein Ziel unser
Vertrauen in die Funktionsfähigkeit von
Start- und Gesellschaft stören bleibt
das Licht aus die Wohnung kalt trifft
uns dieser Terror wirklich alle und ein
weiter so aus Trotz ist unmöglich und
das Problem ist natürlich die
Herausforderung dass 80 Prozent dieser
kritischen Infrastrukturen in den Händen
des privaten Sektors sind also die
werden nicht vom Staat kontrolliert und
deswegen ist es so wichtig dass der
Staat und die privaten Unternehmen jetzt
dringend zusammenkommen und was ist das
nächste Ziel jede Umspannstation jedes
Kraftwerk jede Pipeline jeder Server ist
gefährdet deshalb stehen wir wohl vor
der Herausforderung unsere kritische
Infrastruktur nicht nur besser schützen
zu müssen sondern auch eine Antwort zu
finden auf die Frage wie viel Risiko
sind wir zur Unterstützung der Ukraine
bereit in Kauf zu nehmen
[Musik]